[Music]
turn on it's on no is it what's
happening reject nation maybe you're a
professional get off your phone turn you
dedica whiter I was turning it off like
remain a professional [ __ ] you didn't
tell me we were having morning that's
how I do things here the reality is this
is one daily you might know her from
Collider you should definitely check out
the movie couple channel where she does
plenty of reactions on there a lot of
reviews as well she is fantastic
her and her hobby that upsets a lot of
people that you have a husband oh you
know I get that sometimes when EMS she's
married I'm like but I'm happy yeah all
they're going to do they haven't you saw
she's married I had a chance well one of
the other hosts got engaged to actually
move on she's engaged she's engaged now
and people got really upset you should
have told us all I told Mary now watcher
know we're at a chance hey Aldo Jones
sent this over to me himself
Aldo Jones the man so he has a Deadpool
weird version us English version but the
difference today try not to laugh or
grin I've already lost a lot of people
do this with the French
I caught myself physical pain every
we're having too much fun already
like really fasting okay let's do this
don't laugh don't grin and don't lean
into farce of the cameras as a thing as
a blocker pick um where do you laughing
okay okay alright I got places to be a
face to fix and oh bad
and
[Music]
and what did he do with this [ __ ] all
right
Wow looks really good boys unfortunate
[Music]
oh yeah don't feel smart
so what's it going to be huh long sullen
silence or me ghost one
oh my god
it's true $255 in the opening okay exit
I love that they're effective oh-ho-oh
to lose tragically bring it again and
what did you tonight to find ourselves a
favorite [ __ ] wait you're better than
this
why it's unfortunate
[Music]
they made angel inhumanly strong in my
case it hurts my reflexes so scorched my
nerve endings in fact nobody anything at
green and alright we wait seriously
actually this movie along makes you out
yeah I just want to nibble ternary Wow
from alien 3 wait out here okay the big
house
funny that I only ever see two of you
it's almost like the studio couldn't
afford another x-man nice good one that
would have been an actual cool Cammy
yeah good one oh no Buffy
[Music]
in these moments everything else falls
away the way to be stun you I think I
pass them as far I don't think I did
quite as well as you did
it's almost as if you have emotions and
I was there I not happy about the out
there I have a missionary position I
still feel like I'm not a lot of laughs
that was great that was actually like I
really like a little when he was
slapping a grating around yeah that was
probably one my favorite part that was
where I thought the slicing of Jack
Nicholson is down over me I looked real
yeah perfect Aldo Jones's splicing
effects just keep getting better and
better but Aldo I didn't even fully
smile really yeah I want nothing
I can't even impersonate myself doing
yeah nothing to do it Wow so so great
pass and I know and I'm okay with that
meaning you owe me a picture of yourself
without a shirt on that was the deal we
made that's what I said in the email do
not make me make those emails go public
I would go DJ Trump jr. on you
DJ Trump J stand for I don't even know
what my acronyms mean anymore
I don't know why don't you be here the
whole time the whole time well that was
fun thanks Aldo I appreciate that we
could do a reaction video where the
essential point of it is to not react is
impossible now I want to watch Deadpool
yeah this whole thing's got me and Izzy
Deadpool way I missed the Deadpool world
now I want to I want to get back to it
all right well you guys be good that
notification valve subscriber the real
rejects more importantly don't do any of
that if it's too much work if you can
only do one thing go to the movie couple
channel
about Wendy and Billy definite name
right
Hey pretty sure it's Billy yeah just
Billy they sound similar he looks more
like a billion go check him out there
and check out a low joins of patreon
while you're at it but more importantly
movie couple Channel I was going to say
your patreon no not after this video is
an urn patreon promotion I know when to
promote I know when it's worthy when we
have what what do you what do you do
[Laughter]